sur merci beaucoup de votre attention
bonjour mesdames messieurs plutôt bon
soir moi j'espère que vous allez me
toléré sans mot mars qui nous avons
assez des distances ciation social entre
nous
moi je vais être bref en vo briefant
nous allons
inaugurer notre à présidence durant le
petit déjeuner traditionnel
mais je dois vous dire que
c'était
bien reçu
plus tôt
nous allons voir ont peu de temps libre
au début de notre présidence
à cause
de collectivités chinois
et grâce à l'ouverture des jeux
olympiques d'hiver en chine
nous espérons a terminé à temps
c'est prévu
pour avoir le temps de célébrer ce
festival sportif
évidemment je souhaite aux sportifs du
succès de mon résultat et la montée nu
des jeux olympiques est en totale
nous allons commencer notre présidence
liées aux conséquences entendu en ont
entendu et aujourd'hui vu des défis
globaux à cause de la pandémie le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu doit
assurer à
que nous devons faire notre mieux pour
assurer la stabilité la sécurité et afin
d'éviter les conséquences négatives
économique et sécurisé
les chaînes d'approvisionnement des
produits alimentaires aussi bien que
comme ça à était veut présenter soumis
par le succès général de l'onu pour 2022
et ce sera une très bonne aux
possibilités devrait fermer
nos engagements afin d'éviter les
impacts négatifs économiques et liées à
la pandémie
en plus les mécanismes qui puissent le
sécuriser le 9 février nous allons
parler nous allons débriefer les menaces
à la paix a causés par les actes
terroristes
en particulier quand le directeur
exécutif a déjà
prévu le 10 février nous allons voter à
sur les résolutions du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu
concernant le soudan en plus l'année la
semaine prochaine le 15 février nous
allons la discussion consacrée aux
somalie
ensuite à nous nous allons écouter les
représentants de l'union européenne et
de l'union africaine a en plus dans la
deuxième session de la journée l'envoyé
spécial messieurs grunberg va des
brevets
personnellement ces problèmes
en fait cela me permet
de parler aux ce qui est prévu pour le
16 février consacré la coopération entre
l'onu et certaines n'ont aucun soutien
régional et dans notre cas je parle de
lesseux
et le tc afin d'assurer le maintien de
la paix et nous aspirons qu'avec nos
collègues
finalement
l'organisation va appliquer les efforts
supplémentaires pour stabiliser la
situation avec le soutien de le tester
au kazakhstan en plus nous allons d'un
préfet monsieur sachs et le secteur
général de l'hôte et c'est avec le
secrétaire général les messieurs de
l'onu le monsieur goûter riches et qui
va des référés le conseil décide la tête
de l'onu sur ce problème le 17 février
nous allons célébrer ces temps de la
résolution 22 02
qui
couvre les engagements liés aux
engagements de mise qui est
malheureusement
les manquements des autorités
ukrainiennes
finalement nous voyons aucun mouvement
qui soit fait par kiev pour respecter
les engagements les traités de minsk r
parce que nous allons disent que non
seulement du non respect est aussi
plutôt le non exécution des accords des
muscats par le parlement et crinière et
en plus nous nous allons attirer
l'attention d'une grande réunion
publique à ce problème le 18 février
nous allons discuter des problèmes liés
aux et haïti monsieur halimi va faire
son rapport devant le secteur général de
l'onu et et le vin de février dans la
session du matin nous allons nous
greffer
sur à la mission dans l'airé police
entre africaine a vu que la
participation aux missions n'diaye et
qui va débriefer au nom de l'union
africaine
et qui va parler de leur rôle dans la
promotion des initiatives de
cessez-le-feu dans la république
centrafricaine dans la deuxième session
nous aurons écouter une des mre fier sur
l'irak et le koweït et en particulier le
fonctionnement de la commission de
compensation
couverte par ce que ce mécanisme va
finaliser les engagements pris à genève
et le secrétaire général est où ici le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu va valider
le fonctionnement de cette mission le 23
février nous allons discuter
des missions en particulier monsieur
tourner vers une sorte de qui va parler
de la situation à stabiliser en
palestine et nous allons aussi écouté le
rapport sur l'irak avec messieurs place
kurt ce qui est déjà prévu pour le matin
le 24 février et dans l'après midi le
comité va faire aussi le rapport
dans la dans le cadre d'une commission
et du comité 17-18 nous allons adopter
dans la commission qu 1 041 plus nous
allons prévu à avant discussions mixte
et sur la syrie et les problèmes
humanitaires avec des consultations est
probablement l'aspect et chimiques
martin griffiths et messieurs peterson
et probablement d'autres vont faire le
rapport sur la chimie devant le conseil
de sécurité de l'onu
évidemment comme le 28 février ce sera
le dernier jour du février nous allons
confirmer la date
des travaux à poursuivre maintenant
j'espère que j'ai été agressif
maintenant je suis prêt à répondre à vos
questions maintenant ce la première
question à vous merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup monsieur l'ambassadeur
et nous comprenons que vous êtes très
occupé maintenant j'aimerais poser la
question sur le cren à une petite
surprise est est ce que pour y est
détaillé ce que monsieur poutine vient
de dire alors en ce qui concerne les
relations entre la russie et l'otan et
les préoccupations de la russie ici le
cren décide de respecter d'un mettre en
oeuvre les accords de misc si vous en
pensez est-ce que ça pour être le
premier pas d escalade de la situation
dans la région je pense que c'est faux
de faire le lien entre nos propositions
sur la les garanties de sécurité et l
architecture de sécurité que nous avons
ce mise à l'otan et aux états unis et
que nous avons déjà discuté avec eux par
le passé en particulier
et dans le cadre de l'été au lanceur
parce que la situation en ukraine qui a
été présenté par certains nombres
partenaires aussi dans ton finalement il
s'en concerne pas la sécurité en europe
1 ça ne compte pas ce que c'est une
question plus large nous voyons des
tentatives de faire le lien entre ces
deux sujets différents elle de président
comme quoi
ce concours c'est nous qui agissons pour
la sécurité européenne dans le lien avec
le crâne a évidemment le crâne fait
partie de la sécurité en europe et de
l'europe mais ces deux sujets ne sont
absolument
divisée ne sont pas liés entre eux en
plus vu dans l'ébauché du projet que
nous avons proposé que nous devrions
pouvoir qu'ont les garanties de sécurité
pour la russie qui sont basés sur les
décisions
qui avait été adoptée par tous les états
membres de l'ue est sûre
en
1999 et on 2010 et astana bien sûr oui
il ya un article particulier et
plusieurs articles
qui prévoit le droit pour tout pays de
choisir leur propre voie pour sécuriser
leur
situation et leurs alliés mais à on
parle de la sécurité indivisible et on
dit toujours ce qui est déjà écrit que
la sécurité d'un pays ne peut pas être
garantie au détriment des autres et en
particulier certains partenaires à
l'occident le temps là toujours ignoré
cette approche et c'est pour ça que nous
avons
or poser cette question nous avons reçu
les réponses d'état des états unis mais
quand même
nous avons demandé des éclaircissements
en particulier mais cela renvoie déjà
explicité ce que nous avons déjà
sous-entendu à quand nous parlons de
l'indivisibilité de la sécurité pour
tous les pays c'est pas la réponse que
nous avons déjà envoyé ce misères aux
états unis et à l'otan je pense que
c'est assez clair et simple en ce qui
concerne les accords les traités de misc
j'espère que
doivent être respectées
en plus dès les premiers jours une fois
que les accords de minsk ont été adoptés
nous avons touché agir pour qu'il soit
respecté mais malheureusement les
autorités ukrainiennes a dû façon claire
et évidente ont déjà affirmé que les
traités et les accords de misc 1 ne sont
que peuvent pas être respectés mises en
oeuvres exécutées
en fait il s'agit d'hommes paquet d
engagement qui vise à assurer la
résolution de cette crise sinon rien on
va se passer
votre excellence
continuons le sujet de l'ukraine et dans
l'est de l'europe à anovo en ce qui
concerne à votre intervention au niveau
dessus conseil de sécurité à l'onu vous
avez été très évident très clair parce
qu'il y avait aucune preuve heures
pourquoi
pourquoi est-ce qu'il ya autant de
troupes ou de chars de combat russes qui
sont massés et deuxième question est ce
que vous pensez que les tensions
actuelles
1 peuvent se propager sur d'autres
sujets et concernait la double pensée
globale géant va répondre à votre
deuxième question j'espère que non en ce
qui concerne les tensions
les résultats parfois de façon et
surprise ça veut dire que vous ne
peuvent et
résoudra rien parce qu'il ya toujours
des questions qui apparaissent moi
personnellement je vais essayer de faire
de mon mieux en essayant d'assurer que
le fonctionnement du conseil de sécurité
en février soit souple et le plus
efficace possible à ce qui concerne un
autre groupe massey je suis pas notre
ministre des affaires étranges et de la
défense je peux rien en parler mais je
pense que tu fasses en clair cette
question a été déjà discuté en avril
dernier nous avons déjà une situation
similaire où il y avait des exercices et
des manoeuvres à côté où il y avait des
mouvements ont des trous pas à l'époque
rien à affirmer quoi que ce soit mais du
coup hier on a dit que ça représente
mille ans pour le cren aucun des hauts
fonctionnaires officiel les russes à
rien dire à ce propos c'est surtout à
l'opposé
ils ont réfuté m messieurs lavrov de
notre ministre des affaires étrangères
si ça dépend de la russie on n'y aura
pas de guerre mais dans ce qui concerne
les situations dans les républiques
ex soviétiques est il faut éviter
surtout des provocations qui se bat
dangereuse parce qu'actuellement
on voit les livraisons désarmement de
frapper d'attac en ukraine et y compris
de la part des pays occidentaux et ça
contredit aussi et les accords de mise
car entre autres parce que j'aimerais
avoir faire part de plusieurs chiffres
que je devais citer hier quand nous
parlons de l'ukraine chaque fois nous
disons
que nous sommes vraiment très occupée
par plusieurs choses et qui se passe
dans le pays et en particulier
un la langue russe et qui a langue
naturelle pour la majorité des
ukrainiens
actuellement
vraiment la langue russe et mise en
dehors de l'opinion publique en ukraine
en plus ça contredit leurs engagements
et si on parle des engagements de tours
d2 de l'ukraine j'aimerais faire part de
plusieurs chiffres
de ce qui a été dit
par le secteur général du conseil de
sécurité de la défonce delecray
messieurs daniel offe qui a exprimé de
façon claire que à l'utilisation de la
langue russe dans le monde entier n'est
pas sécurisé à cause de la position de
la russie c'est pour ça que c'est la
raison pour laquelle je vous parle en
anglais est pas un russe
merci beaucoup votre excellence pour
votre des briefing
com
est-ce que nous pouvons attendre
l'arrivée la visite de monsieur lavrorv
votre ministre des affaires étrangères
en ce qui concerne à
la corée du nord et surtout l'accord des
missiles apporte intermédiaire est ce
que c'est un sujet qui pourrait être
traité au niveau du conseil de sécurité
de l'onu en ce qui concerne les
sanctions en cause de l'aggravation de
la situation humanitaire qui sont les
pays acp quand on parle de la corée du
nord
surtout par rapport à la résolution
prise à part le concéder ciotti est ce
que pour y est détaillé à ce sujet me
fais plus ainsi que c'est votre première
question monsieur lavaud ne viendra pas
à cause de son agenda parce que
malheureusement on ne pourrait pas à
venir mais évidemment nous allons
exécuter du façon est stricte et
rigoureuse tous ces instructions qu'il
va nous envoyer en février en ce qui
concerne le sujet de la corée du nord
plusieurs fois nous avons déjà appelé à
assurer un dialogue pour apaiser les
tensions
sur la péninsule de corée
m
et vite parce que personne
va dans le sens
que ça puisse se compromettre ce
processus surtout parce que les
pourparlers ne poursuivent pas depuis
longtemps et oui notre résolution
humanitaire est sur la table parce que
nous avons déjà discuté de cette
résolution avec nos collègues au sein du
conseil de sécurité parce que nous a dit
à plusieurs fois que c'est pas encore le
temps mais vous avez raison parce que la
corée du nord
parce que ça fait partie des sujets même
s'il n'est pas sur la liste en tv parce
que la liste des pays sous sanction est
assez large parce que les populations de
ces pays souffrent à cause des sanctions
parce que 1 parfois ces sanctions sont
implémentés ça concerne non seulement la
corée du nord
quels sont les pays acp et puis ce
souffrir à court de ces sanctions est-ce
que pourriez les tailles et
je vais pas citer exactement mais vous
allez savoir exactement de qui je parle
votre excellence
format arabique des les médias votre
excellence il ya beaucoup de monde dans
le monde entier j'ai apprécié chaque
fois que la russie
confirme sa position mais seulement dans
deux cas et le blâme chaque fois la
russie en particulier il évolua ratio et
aériennes dans l'eure et spatiales au
sud de la syrie et chaque fois quand on
parle de la position de l'israël par
rapport à de la palestine et est-ce que
pourriez détaille la position de la
russie à propos de ces deux sujets en ce
qui concerne nos engagements un tout ce
qui se passe au moyen orient chaque
fournée en profiter de la possibilité de
l'occasion
pour noter que les violations
par les ia israélien de l'espace et aria
en syrie elle n'est pas acceptable parce
que chaque fois nous le dit zaug à
chaque fois que nous parlons de la
situation au moyen orient en ce qui
concerne
des droits des palestiniens à ce que les
peuples avec lise ralison de bonnes
relations mais non seulement ne même pas
ce que la majorité des communautés
internationales au prennent la même
position parce que les situations avec
les gens de la palestine surtout sur les
territoires occupés est inacceptable
parce que cette situation ne doit être
réglée
au sein et dans le cadre
des mécanismes il faut être ferons pas
c'est qu'il faut qu'il soit respectée
parce que nous agissons
du façon active à et parce que je crois
mais doit nous aspirons que déjà au
niveau des conseillers et des hauts
fonctionnaires
politiques
nous avons déjà proposé que cette
question soit résolue au niveau des
ministères concernés
surtout
il faut que cette question
soit discutée si je me trompe pas le 23
février j'espère entendre de bonnes
nouvelles à ce propos à ce sujet ici
merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup votre excellence
je pars le nom de cbs news un anneau à
propos de l'ukraine ma première question
il ya une résolution et résolution
diplomatique à cette crise anne cren et
surtout si le cren joue son rôle en ce
qui concerne les accords de mise car à
mettre en oeuvre et les missions de
l'onu yeux à votre avis ici une
résolution qu'elle roule à jouer en ce
qui concerne les éclaircissements de
l'europa parce que tout à l'heure vous
avez dit que votre gouvernement le
gouverneur de mons co n'a pas répondu
aux propositions des états unis parce
que moscou n'a fait qu'envoyer des
éclaircissements
j'ai bien compris est ce que vous
pourriez détaillé ce sujet s'il vous
plaît
la première claire six manches
de quelle crise est ce que parler de
quel réseau serait ce que par les 6
points 2 de la résolution de la crise
d'un mystique en ukraine dans le donbass
est une chose si on parlait de la crise
qui a été écrit un article du patient
est difficile actuellement avec des
allégations et accusations de la cie
comme quoi c'est la russie avait créé la
crise
si vous parlez de la résolution d'un de
0,2 oui oui je parle de cette résolution
c'est vraiment une feuille de route pour
résoudre la crise un ecrennes
c2s quelque chose qui pourrait résoudre
cette crise c'est notre espoir c'est
de
d'aller
en ce qui concerne en plus le travail à
développer dans le donbass et en ukraine
c'est une chose mais chaque fois qu'il
s'agit
[Musique]
des formats diplomatique et techniques
tout d'abord ya le format normandie qui
a été établi
et en plus le groupe de minsk qui a été
établie ou nous discutons de toutes les
questions techniques malheureusement le
dernier sommet format de normandie a eu
lieu il ya deux ans où il ya plusieurs
accords qui ont été atteints mais ces
accords ne sont pas exécutées est
actuellement les autorités ukrainiennes
en particulier le président craignant
messieurs zelensky insiste sur le fait
d'organiser le nouveau sommet notre
position a est la même à
y a pas besoin d'organiser le nouveau
sommet avant que les accords du dernier
sommet de 2019 soit exécuté parce que
j'ai vu aucun rapport et sur les
rencontres parce que si je me trompe pas
on a déjà eu à l'ailé
les rencontres de trois groupes sur le
plan politique économique et humanitaire
parce que chaque fois tu sur la base
journalière jolie des rapports mais
malheureusement non
azami ukrainien vraiment ne font que du
sabotage des accords du trac et de la
proche de misc
et comme j'ai déjà dit tout d'abord
et tout le monde le dit y compris mes
collègues au niveau du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu parce que les
solutions militaires sont mortes et ne
peut pas être exécutée et la solution
politique qui fait partie des accords de
miss doivent être respectées mais
comment est-ce qu'on peut exécuter les
accords d'un muscle s'il ya une partie
de ces accords
et qui est vraiment fait pas de ces
accords mais refuse de les respecter
mais je ne parle même pas sur le plan
technique mais je parle sur le plan
politique au niveau vraiment supérieur
les accords de misc et les hauts
fonctionnaires et les grands politiques
craignant disent que que les accords de
miss ne peuvent pas être exécutée et le
président alain ce qui a dilué même que
les accords de miss ne peuvent pas être
implémentée et exécutés
mais chaque fois il faut attirer leur
attention sur le fait parce que sinon
sinon on nous dit que à cause du non
respect c'est la russie qui va s'offrir
des sanctions et mais j'aimerais y
revenir à ma deuxième question
y'a pas de réponse à la réponse des
américains
parce que actuellement
et cette question et coordonnée en par
les ministères concernés
mais la lettre a été envoyée aux états
membres de l'otan et aux états unis
parce qu'il s'agirait de nos
éclaircissements de notre compréhension
de la sécurité européenne comme c'est
prévu dans les documents écrits
je parle au nom de rte
on nous avons entendu comme quoi au
washington appelle au dialogue sur le
caine et dans l'ensemble en général mais
en même temps nous avons entendu les
allégations des américains comme quoi il
ya des avions et qui transporte des
troupes des débordements mais en même
temps
le département d'état des états
et des états unis agissent sur cet axe
comment vous pourriez commenter ce sujet
elle me paraît
parce que c' est vraiment question
voisine est proche d'une question
rhétorique parce que hier nous avons dit
lors de notre rencontre
que ce sont les
etats-unis qui ont appelé au fait et
surtout
et monsieur poutine a déjà marqué et
surtout c'est vraiment pour nous c'est
une sorte de provocation à laquelle nous
appellent ce pas ce que ça vraiment
c'est très proche d'une guerre
éventuelle pas ce que parce que
l'ambassadeur américain a parlé de façon
assez modeste mais en même temps le
président ukrainien zelensky a déjà dit
comme les autres aux hauts
fonctionnaires ukrainien ils ont dit tu
fasses au clair qu'ils voient aucune
menace qui pourrait venir de la part us
parce qu'il s'agirait d'une désescalade
détention en même temps on accuse de la
russie de l'aggravation de la situation
parce que tous toutes ces questions
sont liées à la présence comme quoi de
troubles éventuels les russes à le long
de la frontière mais c'est pas vrai du
tout nos troupes ne sont pas proches de
la frontière russo ukrainienne
parce qu'ils occupent leurs positions
habituelles comme d'habitude j'ai aucune
idée d'où viennent ces chiffres de sang
milliers de soldats parce que les
autorités ukrainiennes ont déjà cité le
chiffre de ici au de 8000 soldats russes
je sais pas qui est quand et comment à
faire le compte
surtout le transport des par les forces
spéciales russes je sais pas d'où ce que
ça via et vous avez déjà bien dire
parce que il est créé
et mounis la l'ukraine avec des
armements et les systèmes devra pas ce
que c'est déjà un sujet très sérieux et
dangereux parce que en même temps et à
plusieurs états qui évacue le personnel
c'est une aussi une fête à provocateur
en même temps messieurs les hellènes ski
le président ukrainien a dit dit rien on
se passe il n'y a pas de menace
c'est pour ça que ça n'a fait
qu'aggraver les tensions
je propose de prendre deux questions de
chat s il vous plait
merci beaucoup autres excellence
j'aimerais continuer le sujet et vous
avez déjà dit
vous avez site répéter le chiffre de
cent mille soldats et est-ce que
pourriez nous dire qu'elle a nombre de
soldats russes le long de la frontière
et ma dernière question
pourquoi est ce qu'il ya autant de
divergences à entre la russie et les
etats unis et les états occidentaux l
ukraine parce qu'apparemment et il
paraît comme quoi il ya des accords à
qui des clips de quelle façon il faut
agir pas à pas
en appliquant l'approché proposée par
messieurs péta son concernant la syrie
est ce que vous pourriez éclaircie un
petit peu les accords qui permet de
résoudre ces questions
merci beaucoup de kisa qu est-ce que
vous parler parce que j'ai pas très bien
entendu
[Musique]
parce que si j'ai compris vous
travaillez ensemble
dans le but d'apaiser les préoccupations
bilatérales entre
les ronds et messieurs peterson a déjà
noté que les états unis et la russie ont
une sorte de d'accord qui prévoit la
proche de pas à pas pour résoudre la
crise en syrie
nous devrions avoir la coopération avec
les états unis sur un plus large le
nombre de questions mais c'était pas
notre
approche
de raccourcir cette les des questions à
résoudre conjointement parce que c'est
vraiment à nos intérêts communs parce
que nous en nom propre intérêt de
l'autre par les états unis on joue on le
propose un terrain en ce qui concerne le
sommet entre monsieur baden et poutine à
genève ils ont essayé de résoudre toutes
ces questions
parce qu
il s'agirait de la coopération qui
n'existe pratiquement pas parce que nous
avons repris le dialogue sur la sécurité
stratégique
qui marche dans le sens comme quoi il ya
déjà au moins des conversations
pratiques entre les gens qui s'y
connaissent dans ce sujet nous avons
commencé le dialogue sur la
cybersécurité
qui est vraiment l'objectif entre le
travail de la terre entre les états unis
et la russie
parce que nous avons déjà entamé ses
discussions avec l'administration
précédente de monsieur 1,30 qui
dirigeait à l'époque parce que nous
avons mis les fêtes sur la table en
essayant de résoudre nos divergences en
essayant de nous comprendre nous mêmes
parce que ce dialogue a été repris avec
l'administration américaine actuelle il
ya déjà plusieurs résidents qui ont été
à temps dans ce domaine mais nous avons
quand même des préoccupations sur la
cybersécurité et les menaces ici non
seulement pour certains pays mais aussi
pour les états unis parce que cette
question était discuté entre autres un
plus il ya d'autres types dialogue sur
d'autres questions comme par exemple
l'iran le surgé iraniens parce que les
deux partis ils ont l'intérêt que
l'accord et le pacte gagnant le pack
global sur liront souhait respecté
complètement
mais à ma connaissance des négociations
à vienne sont en cours
et avec certaines espoir fragile nous
espérons que cet accord puisse être
trouvé
et nous espérons poursuivre le dialogue
sur l'afghanistan parce que nous avons
les trois au format élargi avec le
pakistan la chine
qui sert d'un outil important dans la
résolution des questions liées avec
l'afghanistan
en ce qui concerne le cren
nous avons nous avons pu organiser une
conférence de presse à apa pas ce que
c'est vraiment large et sujet mais ne
vont pas nous mettre d'accord sur les
quais n'est pas ce que l'ukraine est
devenu vraiment une carte et jeu
politique en fait
dans nos relations
avec
les états unis avec certains pays
occidentaux
et probablement
alinéa les états unis n'ont pas
l'intérêt à résoudre cette crise parce
que vous avez déjà mons neuilly entre
autres parce quand j'ai fait
l'intervention au niveau du conseil de
sécurité comme monsieur tomassi grand
fils d'un
affaissement intervention elle a parlé
non seulement de la crise en cours entre
l'ukraine et la russie qui n'existent
pas du tout en fait à part tous les
autres problèmes que nous voyons je
parle de jeu pas de la crise dont le
format est dans la forme qu'il avait
essayé de proposer
il n'a pas mentionné en commun à propos
des accords de musique dans son
intervention en fait qui témoigne du
fait que si vous voulez résoudre la
crise en ukraine vous devez
encourager et les autorités ukrainiennes
et le cren et pour que le cren respecte
les accords de misc c'est vraiment un
sujet de grande ampleur
parce que c'est des moments c'est
vraiment devenu une question et qui a
couvert toutes les autres questions qui
existe entre nous et qu'on vous le
connaissez les états unis et a
probablement ils sont plus prudents sur
ce sujet même par rapport à la position
des haut parleurs officielle au kenya ce
qui concerne la présence des trappes des
troupes le long de la frontière où à
côté de la frontière j'ai aucune idée à
ce propos m je sais pas et je ne
comprends pas d'où viennent ces chiffres
qui ont été cités c'est pas moi qui les
otites et parce que personne ne sait
combien de troupes il yaa est voisine de
la frontière
nous savons exactement qui se trouvera
en dehors des frontières des des états
unis parce que ça elle compte environ
cent soixante quinze mille soldats en
dehors des états unis en plus il ya
plusieurs représentants des troupes des
états de l'otan qui sont à côté des
frontières russes voilà la situation
telle qu'elle est
est ce que vous pensez posé la question
à votre ministère de la défense je ponds
je pense pas posé ma cette question à
mon ministère de la défense de la russie
pas ce que c'est les mystères de la
défense russe qui doit à parler
directement
mais je sais pas pourquoi est-ce que
c'est mon ce soit moi qui devrait poser
la question au ministère russe de la
défense les autres et qu'il doit poser
cette question et nous allons apprendre
encore en question du chat ayez passons
à la salle
merci
j'aimerais poser la question au nom de
la société presse du pakistan
malgré le fait est la position prise par
plusieurs états y compris par le russie
si on parle de la crise économique est
profonde
et surtout le président
entend que le la le puits président du
conseil de ce qu'était ce que vous
pourriez détaillé à un petit peu plus la
question arrête parce que si j'ai bien
compris vous avez parlé de l'afghanistan
à merci la situation en afghanistan
c'est vraiment une très bonne question
et a passé que nous agissons pour que
plus d'attention soit portée à la
situation en afghanistan surtout
l'assistance humanitaire
parce que actuellement la situation
s'aggrave ce qu'on entend mais il ya des
questions
internes et un travailliste année qui
doivent être résolus mais qui sont
bloqués par les quotas américain il ya
plusieurs parmi nos collègues et qui
disent
qui a désavoué qui peuvent être
transférées et vers les afghanistani
mais vu ce qui a été décidé
ça résout pas ce puzzle
et je suis pas sûr que ça puisse aider
l'afghanistan parce que c'est notre
priorité commune
de maintenir la stabilité en afghanistan
et
nous appelons le taliban
et les autres à exécuter ce qu'ils ont
dit au début nous voient nous voulons
avoir
un gouvernement avait ni stan et
inclusif qui puisse assurer la stabilité
qui va battre contre le terrorisme en
afghanistan contre le trafic de drogue
pour observer et maintenir les droits de
l'homme en afghanistan y compris pour
les enfants et pour les femmes entre
autres et nous aspirons que les
résolutions
à
20,20
6,15 qui a été adoptée le 28 décembre
dernier permettra non seulement aux
nations-unies mais au pays à soutenir
l'afghanistan à construire l'assistance
humanitaire pour que la défense puisse
survivre la période des verts
mais en ce qui concerne
le décongèle d avoir glané je suis
complètement d'accord avec vous là
dessus c'est à vous la parole merci
je m'appelle et qui sonne je parle de
rabbi newspaper en ce qui concerne le
cren
apparemment ce n'était pas suffisant
pour lesquelles je sais
juste un petit suivi entre autres à vous
avez déjà dit que l'ambassadeur et le
président ukrainien et l'ambassadeur
américain au lors de la séance au
conseil de sécurité de l'onu ils ont dit
que leur pays se tient et appelle fait
les rencontres à ce niveau en ce qui
concerne les situations en libye
et le conseil de sécurité a plusieurs
fois trois fois si je ne me trompe pas a
déjà discuté de cette question il ya six
mois
est ce que pour y est détaillée plus de
la position de votre pays à propos de la
libye est ce que vous avez reçu quelques
quelques propositions
de là
à propos de la nomination de monsieur qu
aux biches merci beaucoup d' avance
est évidemment l'ambassadeur kényans ont
nations-unies à ceux tenus cette
rencontre parce que
parce que ces rafles être vraiment le
discours a que les autorités
ukrainiennes a appuyé à ce sujet parce
qu'il ya pas de surprise là dessus
j'espère qu'il va se tenir notre
rencontre
du 17 février qui sera consacré au
respect des accords de minsk j'espère
qu'ils puissent nous rejoindre et qui va
faire
le rapport évidemment il sera bienvenu
le 17 février en ce qui concerne la
situation en libye en fait hier déjà
nous avons adopté les résolutions qui
est prévoit l'élargissement a encore
pour trois mois de la mission a pour
nous la raison est très simple pour ce
fait nous voudrions que le secteur
général là parce qu'il ya déjà un
article dans cette résolution qui fait
référence à la résolution précédente que
le secrétaire général
puisse a nommé un envoyé spécial des
nations-unies ont les billes
dans l'immédiat
à ce que
les délais c'est plus ou moins 10 6 mois
d'avril
le contrat avec stéphanie williams
williams expire ngoyo avoir le nom avant
cette date de la personne qui
serait agréée par le conseil de sécurité
de l'onu parce que monsieur rajhi qui
devrait agir dans ce sens nous pensons
que
ça puisse être bon parce que ça va
engager les activités à tripoli et en
plus le processus politique ultérieur
surtout dans le cadre des élections
on y arrive sans
retard
c'est vraiment tout d'abord ce sont les
gens de la libye qu'ils doivent
décider ils doivent se mettre d'accord
et sur les dates et sur le format
et nous pensons
que ces élections doivent être
inclusives et chacun doit avoir la
possibilité d'y participer
et dans ce cas nous inspirons que le
processus pour l'éthique et la
résolution un pisse progresser
je pense que nous allons prendre encore
juste deux dernières questions s'il vous
plaît c'est à vous la parole
votre excellence bonsoir
j'ai pas de la chesnaie tunisienne
je vous avais déjà mentionné de la
diplomatie à haut-parleurs mai mais il
ya plusieurs questions qui concernent
seulement l'ukraine mais aussi la syrie
qu'est ce qu'on pensait à propos de la
diplomatie au par le géant tant que le
président du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu
comment est ce que vous pourriez
agir dans ce sens là à propos de la
diplomatie à haut-parleurs c'est
vraiment très bon exemple de ce qu'on
appelle diplomatie à haut-parleurs pas
ce que c'est une question elle
l'expression que j'ai utilisée j'étais
juste pour le fait pour attire
l'attention parce que ça n'a rien à voir
avec la réalité parce que en fait
parce que ça concerne la politique
intérieure d'un pays
parce qu'en fait c'était préparé depuis
le ton avant que la rencontre soit
entamée nous sommes nous opposer au fait
que le vote selon la procédure soit
effectué parce que ça ne concerne pas
les vraies questions de la réalité ça ne
parle que des faits que de fausses
nouvelles à propos de la diplomatie de
hauts parleurs
pendant ma présidence je serais pas
capable d'arrêter
de laisser parler les autres qui
utilisent cette approche de la
diplomatie haut parleur mais nous avons
déjà arrêté ray il dit plusieurs fois
que le conseil de sécurité de l'onu y
compris al tous les états membres du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu doivent
éviter blâmer les autres nous devons
être capables d'être plus engagés dans
la résolution des choses et pragmatique
dans les solutions pragmatiques
et j'ai déjà dit plusieurs fois pendant
plusieurs années
que le conseil de ce cas de l'onu puisse
attendre les accords et sur l'amazone
des questions mais vous poser des
questions à propos à propos de la guerre
à propos des riders je comprends que
vous agissez en tant que média on
voulait avoir des fait chaud mais le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu fonctionne
parfois il fait des choses et qu'il doit
faire surtout il ya des choses qui sont
faites derrière les rideaux et qui
n'apparaissent pas sur le premier repas
j'ai des médias et je pense qu'encore
juste deux dernières questions merci
merci beaucoup votre excellence je pars
de l'agencé turque en ce qui concerne le
poursuit de la situation en ukraine
alena les etats-unis et les autres ont
déjà parlé des sanctions qui puisse être
imposée en cas d'invasion de la russie
en ukraine et comment ma deuxième
question concerne la syrie est-ce que
penser que le comité conditionnelle de
syrie puissent se rencontrer à genève et
semoy
en ce qui concerne les sanctions
nous avons subi des sanctions aux
plusieurs fois la première chose
deuxième chose les menaces
si je me trompe at et les actions sévère
dur je sais plus le terme qui a été
utilisé mais la chose la plus ironique à
propos de ces sanctions on parle on
parle des sanctions avant que moi que
c'est qu'ils arrivent on parle des
sanctions préventive parce que mercier
le sénateur menendez
aux états unis a déjà parlé qu'il faut
punir la russie parce que la russie a de
mauvaises intentions
déjà il a dit que malgré malgré ce qui
se passe les actions doivent être
imposées
en plus nous avons entendu plusieurs
affirmations des haut parleurs des hauts
fonctionnaires pour l'éthique craignant
à ce propos la chose la plus amusante
parce que depuis longtemps nous avons
déjà dit et notre ministre des affaires
étrangères monsieur lavrov déjà depuis
l'époque de porochenko le pardon c'est
le fait que la le cren et ne respecte
pas et n'exécute pas les accords de
musique mais c'est la russie qui est
puni et depuis longtemps nos ce front et
nous sommes obligés de vivre avec ces
sanctions
dans tous les cas
j'espère qu'il y aura assez
du sens raisonnable daley
et de progresser mais je sais pas
comment les veaux comment ils vont
répondre je vais pas vous tromper ainsi
conseil aux comités continue de syrie
comme ici à peterson a dit le 26 janvier
dernier parce que normalement
je pense pas que cette rencontre
à l'époque je je pensais du mois de
janvier à propos d'une rencontre
éventuelle du comité constitué de série
à je sais que les préparatifs sont en
cours mais je ne sais pas encore la date
exacte
merci beaucoup mais votre excellence
ensuite j'aimerais poursuivre a
brillamment deux sujets qui ont été
entamées
les ministères sont en train de préparer
les ministères aux éclaircissements
américaine
est ce que vous attendez
quelques documents qu'ils puissent
surgir ou apparaître et ma question
concerne le myanmar parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est l'anniversaire
au myanmar
et en plus nous avons vu plusieurs hauts
fonctionnaires des nations unies et déjà
cette question a été discutée au haut
niveau du conseil de sécurité mais quand
même et il n'y a pas de d'actions qui
avaient été prises et pour adresser le
message pouvoir et les autorités pour
prévenir
ce qui se passe dans le riz et parce que
parce qu'actuellement ce conflit
progresse dans le sens d'une guerre
civile comment est-ce que la russie
puisse résoudre cette crise
a à propos des deux premières questions
ma réponse à la va vite à la réponse
notre réponse à la réponse américaine
n'a pas encore été finalisé
le porte parole
de notre président comme monsieur
lavrova déjà entretenu des pourparlers
par téléphone avec le secrétaire d'état
américain
parce que c'est un cours évidemment ça
va venir
en ce qui concerne
des événements si négatifs ne sont pas
prévues en ce qui concerne la situation
au myanmar
lorsqu'il conscience si ça pouvait dans
le sens d'une guerre civile au nom
évidemment nous tous nous tâchons une
grande attention
pour que cette question soit résolue
parce que si les gens du myanmar ne peut
pas être fait rien d'autre
parce qu'on ne peut compter que sur les
efforts diplomatiques
que la mauvaise paix sociale des nations
unies est en train d'entreprendre
et qui est vraiment engagée et qui a
commencé à opérer
récemment y en marre je pense pas que ce
soit un secret pour vous mais le conseil
de sécurité a est en train de travailler
à propos de cette question
à jeu je vais dire une chose
je ne veux pas être quelqu'un qui va
vous trompez
à ce qui concerne la résolution
parce que je veux pas être panther
je sais pas si c'est tout
ce serait pas juste
si vous permettez
alors ma question ça concerne les
accords de minsk
s'il vous plaît c'est évident pour tout
le monde m'a beaucoup parlé à l''onu que
les accords 2000 ce que c'est le
seulement diplomatique visant à résoudre
la situation d'un bassin et les hauts
fonctionnaires eux craignant des clercs
ouvertement que l'ukraine ne respectera
pas les accords de minsk les pays
occidentaux multiplient les fournitures
de l'armement à l'ukraine à ce contexte
là qu'est ce que vous allez discuter le
18 février évidemment la diplomatie de
hauts parleurs c'est pas notre cas mais
bon on voit de multiplier les
déclarations que les accords de minsk ne
sont pas respectées je vais en son genre
en russie georges
ap
c'était à propos des à propos des
accords de miss moi je vais répondre un
russe si vous n'avez rien contre
tout d'abord c'est le septième
anniversaire
chaque année
au conseil de sécurité nous entamons ce
sujet pour attirer l'attention non
seulement du conseil de sécurité des
deux hommes et de toute la communauté
internationale à ce que l'ukraine depuis
longtemps d'abord à saboter les accords
de musique et maintenant elles refusent
ouvertement de les suivre de les
respecter comme j'ai déjà dit nous
allons discuter non pas le respect des
accords de mais le non respect des
accords de minsk à maintes reprises ce
qu'on vous le savez nous avons déjà fait
ça et c'est la russie qu'on essaie de
faire pas porte tout chapeau en
en la présentant comme une partie des
accords de minsk et en parlant de ses
engagements on les respecte et on a
plusieurs fois demandé nos collègues à
nos sites et les engagements qui ont été
pris par la russie dans le cadre de
l'accord de minsk nous n'avons pas reçu
de questions ça concerne le kick sa
conscience qu'il est donc basse mais
personne ne veut nous entendre mais où
va réitérer ses tentatives et je pense
qu'il faut attirer l'attention à cette
question et essayer
et d'encourager nos partenaires
d'encourager leurs subalternes à kiev de
reprendre ces discussions reprendront
cette question parce que sans cela on
n'a pas d'autre solution du conflit plus
de temps passe plus malheureusement dans
de basses s'éloigne du piège
on en parlait entre autres que
vous avez dit vous pouvez même que le
pen suit le format de la politique
étrangère des états unis peut être c'est
pas avec les ukrainiens qu'il faut
parler qu'il faut discuter les accords
de miss mais avec quelqu'un qui peut
vraiment résoudre quelque chose qui peut
vraiment décidée oui nous le faut nous
parlons aux collègues américains au ciné
les demandes ont d'influencer leurs
amis ukrainiens
mais la compréhension des accords de
minsk
par nos partenaires américains et encore
moins prolongée que celle de nos
collègues du format normandie
peut-être c'est assez je vous remercie
chers amis
je vais vous voir souvent pendant ce
mois moi-je pas de choix heureusement
heureusement je n'ai pas d'autre choix
que de vous rencontrer plusieurs fois
pendant ces mois
je vais